Paolo Patuzzo staunt jedes Mal, wenn er
über die Rialto-Brücke läuft:
Was ist vom Charme dieser Stadt geblieben,
die jedes Jahr von Millionen von Touristen
überlaufen wird?
Wie kann sich Venedig vor diesem
Besucheransturm schützen?
Als Foto-Kulisse allein kann dieses
Kulturerbe nicht überleben
– davon ist Paolo überzeugt.
Der Liebe für diese Stadt wegen
suche ich Orte und Menschen,
welche Venedig noch am Leben erhalten.
Denn es gibt genügend Leute,
die gegensteuern,
die diese Stadt wieder in ein neues
Fahrwasser bringen wollen.
Paolo selbst lebt vom Tourismus –
wie fast alle Venezianer.
Das ist sein Dilemma.
Mit besonderen Stadtführungen will er
auf die Probleme aufmerksam machen
– wie in seinem Stadtteil, wo die Mieten
steigen wegen der vielen Ferienwohnungen,
wo immer mehr Einheimische
wegziehen.
In seiner Stammkneipe ist der
Niedergang Venedigs
und das Aussterben der Venezianer
das große Thema.
Vor zwanzig Jahren wimmelte es hier
noch von Handwerkern.
Da wurde noch produziert für die
Bevölkerung:
Polsterer, Schreiner, Schlosser,
Buchbinder – alles ist verschwunden.
Heute macht niemand mehr Matratzen,
repariert keiner mehr Schuhe.
Das kränkt den Stolz der Venezianer.
Was ist übrig von ihrer einst so reichen
Handelsmetropole?
Paolo zeigt den alten Fisch- und
Gemüsemarkt.
Auch er ist nur noch reine
Touristen-Attrappe
in einer Stadt, in der immer weniger
Menschen wohnen und wirklich leben.
Es gibt hier mehr Touristen, die
fotografieren, als Kunden, die einkaufen.
Das provoziert, und deshalb überlegen
einige Fischverkäufer,
sich jetzt als Statisten, als Schauspieler
in einer Tourismus-Kulisse,
bezahlen zu lassen.
Zum gigantischen Problem werden
auch die Kreuzfahrtschiffe.
Stefano Micheletti ist schockiert.
Denn seit Jahren laden die Riesen nicht
nur Massen von Tagestouristen ab,
sondern bedrohen die Fundamente
der Lagunenstadt.
Die großen Schiffsschrauben
haben einen Kolbeneffekt,
wühlen den gesamten Untergrund auf:
Lehm und Schlamm werden so nach
und nach aus der Lagune
ins offene Meer gespült.
Die Folge: Venedig, das auf Holzpfählen
gebaut ist,
sackt immer mehr ab und könnte
irgendwann ganz im Wasser versinken.
Stefano Micheletti gibt sich nicht
geschlagen.
Seine Bürgerinitiative hat es geschafft,
dass nicht noch mehr Kreuzfahrtschiffe
die Stadt anfahren dürfen.
Wenn so ein Schiff vorbeifährt, sinkt in den
umliegenden Kanälen das Wasser jeweils
um 20 Zentimeter und steigt danach wieder
wegen der Verdrängung
Das sind enorme Kräfte, die natürlich
an den Fundamenten der Paläste,
Kirchen und Brücken in Venedig nagen.
Mit seinem Engagement schafft sich
Stefano Micheletti nicht nur Freunde.
Denn Venedigs Hafenbehörde hat Millionen
in moderne Kreuzfahrtterminals investiert.
Aufgrund der Proteste der Bevölkerung
kann sie jetzt aber nur die Hälfte benutzen.
Seit vier Jahren hören wir diese Ängste,
dass unsere Schiffe Venedig sogar
rammen könnten.
Ich kann nur immer wieder versichern:
Auch mit dem größten Kreuzfahrtschiff
ist dieses Risiko gleich null.
So wirbt die Kreuzfahrt-Industrie weiterhin
für die Fahrt vorbei an San Marco
als weltweit einzigartig – und verdient
daran Millionen.
Doch die Front gegen die Kreuzfahrtschiffe
wächst – auch wegen der Abgase,
die aus den Schornsteinen dampfen.
Immer mehr Venezianer zweifeln, ob
der derzeitige Kurs ihrer Stadt
der richtige ist.
Die großen Bauvorhaben werden
bislang von der Flughafen- und
der Hafengesellschaft entschieden.
Da geht es nur um Wachstum:
immer mehr, immer größer.
Für das Wohlergehen der Stadt fehlt
jedoch jede Strategie.
Paolo Patuzzo macht das traurig
und wütend.
55.000 Einwohner werden jedes Jahr
von 30 Millionen Touristen überrollt.
Dafür braucht es radikale Gegenstrategien.
Es ist paradox, aber
der beste Tourist für Venedig ist der,
der nicht in die Stadt kommt.
Wir sind mehr als voll – mit 30 Millionen
Besuchern im Jahr.
Paolo glaubt, dass der Tourismus in Venedig
wieder in normale Dimensionen
gelenkt werden muss.
Dazu müssten alle Venezianer auf einen
Teil des großen Geschäfts verzichten,
um ihre Stadt zu retten.